ils étaient plus d'une centaine de
dirigeants internationaux des têtes
d'affiché comme stéphane bancel pdg de
moderna groupes pharmaceutiques ou
encore jamie dimon pdg de la banque
américaine jp morgan
tous venus au sommet de shoes france
avec un intérêt pour l'attractivité
économique de la france aujourd'hui le
plan de relance est décaissé très
rapidement nous avons déjà engagé plus
d'un tiers du plan de relance
et puis il ya une deuxième série de
questions qui d'ailleurs présage
d'autres investissements dans les mois à
venir c'est sur la décarbonation et sur
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique
pour cette quatrième édition du sommet
de shoes france 22 projets
d'investissements ont été annoncée pour
un montant de 3,5 milliards d'euros et
7000 emplois à la clé c'est le cas du
groupe pharmaceutique allemand merck
présent sur 11 sites en france comme
grand groupe mondial du secteur
pharmaceutique
nous avons décidé de continuer à
investir dans les capacités de
croissance avec du matériel plus
performant pour soutenir la production
et les clients autour du monde et nous
avons deux fantastiques collaboration
avec des universités les instituts
scientifiques parce que nous avons un
partenariat de longue date avec le
gouvernement français
la principale annoncé l'ouverture dans
le nord de la france d'une usine de
production de batteries pour les
véhicules électriques avec de possibles
répercussions pour le territoire des
yvelines avec l'annoncé de
l'investissement chinois notamment en
matière de batteries
on sait bien que c'est une filière qui
est fondamental pour la filière auto et
qui est une pierre très structurante ici
dans les yvelines
et donc c'est une excellente nouvelle
effectivement de voir que on a des
investissements qui vont aussi in fine
et irriguer le territoire
de son côté la région ile de france mène
aussi une politique pour favoriser
l'attractivité du territoire francilien
nous avons identifié des sites et
notamment des friches industrielles qui
sont prêtes à l'emploi et ses sites
prête à l'emploi nous allons les mettre
à la disposition des patrons nous avons
aussi mis en place une équipe qui est
chargé d'accueillir y compris les
impatriés en 2020 la france reste le
pays le plus attractif d'europe avec 985
projets d'investissement